hi this is sal khan of the khan academy  and i just wanted to thank everyone out  there for another great year  we're now reaching over 10 million  students per month and many of y'all  have noticed the amazing partnerships  and the content  that we've been able to work together to  put out there but one thing i do like to  remind people at this time of year is  that we are a 501c3 not-for-profit  organization and the only reason why we  can exist while we can continue to put  out this content is with the help of  supporters like yourself so i'll just  throw that out there  if you're in the position whether it's  five dollars ten dollars or a lot more  than that uh every penny is very much  appreciated by us at khan academy so we  can continue to try to deliver a free  world-class education to the world